numbers if you like to sit thank you
thank you very tops
right everybody welcome to the July
counts the full council meeting as an
introduction could I just remind any
speakers could you ensure that you speak
directly into the microphone from a
reasonable distance otherwise your
voices will not be picked up on the
recording and it is quite possible to
share moment here you can I ask for
apologies for absence chairman we've
received apologies from pencil gray
councillor Haley's councillor Kendall
councillor Lawton councillor O'Donnell
councillor Perry councillor pain
councillor Richards council Richie's
councillor Saints council of auditory
and councillor Williams I would just
like to report to members you've heard
that councillors pain and Saint how
given their apologies I'm pleased to
hear that I had an email overnight from
council Saint who as you know has been
through quite a long time an extended
period in hospital he is at home and he
is very much looking forward to getting
back onto his feet as it were to joining
us as soon as possible
councillor pain is also ill in hospital
and we sent him I'm sure half the
council and all members are very best
wishes for a speedy recovery
and although I haven't got the same
update from capsule Williams I think we
should also be offering him our best
wishes for recovery and of course
council center as well I now invite
members and officers to make any
declarations of interest to the meeting
right moving on for those I know we have
two sets of minutes an hour seek a
proposer and a seconder to the minutes
of the meeting
last fall council meeting 24th of April
2018 can I have a proposal please cuts
the thermal counselor Barnes seconding
it are we agreed
thank you and the second meeting which
is a 16th of May 2018 can have Raposa
counselor fielding and the second
counselor Giles we agreed thank you very
much
I'd like to make a following
announcements firstly I'd like to
congratulate mailer daemon for her 25
years that she has been with the
Stratford district council and she's I'm
delighted to say come to join us here
this afternoon so then I'd like if you'd
like come forward and we'll present you
with your certificate 25 years
moving on and I would just like to wish
we have had to counselors had a birthday
today also Adam's birthday I think was
over the weekend so very happy birthday
to you and I understand there is counsel
organ has birthday today is that correct
and then you have your birthdays to you
as well I do apologize you need to speak
to your colleagues who didn't inform me
but I'm sure we all wish you a very
happy birthday as well I think right
ladies and gentlemen I wish to bring two
points to counsels attention firstly as
you all know the council has a policy of
encouraging members to use electronic
devices such as laptops iPads or
smartphones as this has both
environmental benefits reducing the
amount of paper used by the council and
the cost of printing and allows
councillors access a wide range of
information electronically for the same
reason they use it former council
meetings are supported for the purposes
of viewing the agenda or accessing other
council related documents relevant to
the discussions taking place the use of
any other or any mobile device device at
meetings for any other purpose needs
careful thought to clear reason
strengths exercise care are because
inappropriate use could lead to a legal
challenge against a contentious decision
or it could bring a complaint against
members for failure to show disrespect
to others or bringing the council or the
office of members interested repute
under our code of conduct as chair of
the council I would therefore urge
members to be careful when using mobile
devices at meetings and ensure that
their use is relevant
business being considered as counselors
may be aware the council already has a
social media policy enforce as part of
the code of conduct but the monitoring
officer will be bringing forward a
report on the effect of the current
policy and main due course suggest an
amendment to that policy secondly many
councillors served before the number of
councillors was reduced to the current
fed of six members councils will be
aware that that reduction increased the
workload on councillors both informally
with large awards and in the requirement
to attend formal meetings whilst
councillors understandably have
commitments outside of the council I
would encourage those members who find
they're unable to attend meetings to
appoint substitutes as soon as possible
to ensure that there is no risk of
meeting suffering from a shortage of
elected members thank you
a short break so I just been asked by
Caroline just have a very short break
counselors as is normal for the chairman
to give a list of where he's been
involved since the last cup full council
meeting I've been a little bit racy and
decided to give you a picture or thing
because I think this demonstrates not
only to councillors who may be aware
what I'm doing but this is a videoed
meeting and I think it demonstrates the
broad range of interests that other
people have in this council where they
want this council to be involved in
activities going forward so firstly the
mayor of Stratford's mayor making and
civic service followed by buckling
palace garden party which the were not
there were one or two members for this
world there the Bishop of Coventry is
evening reception Stratford River
Festival the line folded lunch with
David Wilson Holmes and the guide dogs
for the blind
Coventry Solihull and works of school
games the south works a team was led by
their teacher sherry Martin from the
Church of England Primary School in
Tamworth and Arden councillor Atkinson
was not actually taking part but I'm
sorry nice to see a member of your
wallet your your school in your ward was
taking part
followed by celebrating the hundredth
anniversary of the founding of the RAF
followed by a civic service for the RAF
and this is their hundredth anniversary
logo which we've been authorized to
display today which is celebrating 100th
anniversary and finally second thoughts
drama group much to do about nothing at
the bear pit theatre last week there
have been a number of other
organizations who've invited me to
attend events which regrettably I have
been unable to attend because of either
other commitments oh I just couldn't get
there but that gives a summary of what
I've been up to and then moving on final
point of my address is as you know which
we agreed in the budget process that we
would set some money aside to
commemorate the hundredth anniversary
of the Armistice in 1918 I'd like to
thank Tony Perkis and Craig Bourne for
the very detailed work they were already
commenced to make sure that we deliver a
suitable commemoration there will be a
service of remembrance for staff members
and I hope guests at some stage during
the week commencing the fifth of
November I'd commend to all members to
try and attend that because that is our
district's commemoration of the events
100 years ago and the Armistice research
has been done through a county worker
role of Honor and we are contacting all
parish councils to make sure the list
that we have of the fallen is complete
so the grateful if members could come in
when their speeds their parish councils
could ensure that they do respond to
those time is quite tight in fact very
tight because we need to make sure that
we have a complete run of honor and if
embarrassing if we miss somebody out the
roll of Honor is going to be bound in a
leather-bound document with our logo on
the front and that will be available for
anybody to examine in this or in this
office Tony and Craig are proposing
adding on to our district council a
micro website which will include a list
of all those who have died their home
some images the work of women at war and
any other features they think
appropriate or if any members consider
they'd like to have input into that I'm
sure they're welcome but it would also
enable schoolchildren or anybody else to
carry out research on the district by
using the same database that were
creating for the role of honor we've
invited the works a young poet laureate
who's accepted the offer and will be
writing a poem and she will be reading
that out at the
service remembrance we have in November
the number of statues have been
identified at being marketed by what in
connection with the British Legion and
the intention is that District Council
will acquire all of those and it will be
set in I think Bancroft garden with a
small statue alongside the role of honor
in this office we have made an offer to
all the main row centers that's also
Biddeford Henley coins and ships turn
silence Dudley was born if they wish to
acquire one as well and five of those
have so far accepted if any parishes
wishes to acquire them on their behalf
we won't be funding that but it would be
great if parishes want to join in that
to enable them to do so that ladies and
gentlemen concludes my rather longer
than normal announcements I therefore
now like to invite the leader of the
council if you'd like to make his
announcement Thank You chair two things
the first is the LGA conference which I
attended a week before last there were
two key points coming out of that that I
think are worth sharing with members the
first days that had warm very well
attended session the people present most
of whom were councillors were asked when
they thought councils had been
performing up their best the answer was
by a decent majority now when you think
of what councils are being through and
the pressures have been under over
pretty much of the last decade that he
said I think a really good achievement
the people think that councils are
performing up there
now there was one other point that I
think was quite interesting that was
raised in a question which I think
begins to indicate the way the balance
might be shift in between councils and
the center because one person raised the
issue about us councils become more
self-funding if the center wants things
doing and aren't prepared to pay for it
should we actually turn around and say
no personally I think the answer to that
is yes but it is an interesting picture
of how the balance may well be shifting
between local councils and the center
the second thing I actually want to
mention is on last Friday the 13th as it
happens we went to a Federation of small
businesses launched and we won an award
we've got a little glass plaque and a
certificate and this is for the best
small business friendly program or
campaign awarded to struck fir'd on Aven
District Council and this was for the
Victorian market that was held before
Christmas and it was interesting that in
the comments made about the award they
actually said that in many cases it was
worn against the artist because it
really was bitterly cold that day as
speaking as a town councillor as well
my fellow town councillors councillor
fragile II councillor Roth councillor
phytic and myself can actually say it
really was cold I think I'd like to pay
tribute to the work done by Nancy
singleton and puppet a metalic for the
work they did and finally I think an
honorable mention
the wonderful disguise donned by the
previous chairman as Prince Albert it
really was
excellent George Atkinson and we do we
do wonder what disguised our current
chair will wear this year thank you
thank thank you leader well you will
have to wait and see I'd like to now
call on to the head of paid service to
present his report Thank You chairman
I've just got two announcements the
first one I would like to do some work
that the council's been conducting
probably more than twelve months now
with the range of partners and an
organization called disabled go to
produce access guides in more than 300
locations including ledger centers
theaters libraries tourist attractions
and parks all of which have been visited
in person by an experienced disabled go
surveyor the access guides provide lots
of factual information who can get
access and disability from lots of
different perspectives not only mobility
impairment but also learning disability
sensory impairment dementia autism and
mental health every access guide is
produced using the same standards and
measures ensuring consistency and
accuracy and on the 5th of July the
access cards were launched at an events
at the RSC s of the place and what they
would there would provide visitors and
residents with all the information they
need to decide whether the venue that I
wish to go to within this distance is
right for them the second announcement
is related to customer feedback the
council routinely undertake reception
surveys so these are customers who come
in and access services from from the
ladies and gents of work front-of-house
and we've been conducting the survey
since my not 2009 and the latest results
have produced the best set of figures
that we've actually had today's
satisfaction with the length of
some residents had to wait now stands at
its highest recorded level of 89% 96% of
those surveyed expressed satisfaction
with the appearance of the staff and
that is the highest figure that we've
ever had
satisfaction with the courtesy of staff
is at its highest level of 96%
satisfaction with the helpfulness of
staff is now at its peak 95 percent and
resident satisfaction with the knowledge
of staff is increased to 95 percent
finally in terms of speed of service
that again is at its highest level since
we started this at 95 percent so
hopefully you'll join me in welcoming
that brilliant set of responses thank
you they would all join a post service
in congratulating his staff on those
excellent results thank you thank you
point five formally the council vote
thinks I put this on the agenda on the
assumption I'm staking me that councilor
st. would be here because the number of
former councillors had requested
since he was unable to be here at the
last meeting they would like to have an
opportunity to make comments as he is
not here I have asked them to stand down
and they are very much hoping the next
council meeting that they will that we
can defer this item to them because the
moss do you have a thank you answer wars
right we we then move on to is everybody
happy with that by the way that we defer
public participation we have no members
no questions from members of the public
so we can move on to consider point
seven which I now call on the leader of
the council to present report on the
section pointment of ahead of page
service
House members are may know and many of
you participated in it we went through a
recruitment exercise to recruit a head
of paid service to replace Dave Webb
when he retires at the in December we
have offered the pose to Isabelle Edgar
Brianna song and I have to say there was
a very strong field of candidates I
think we were very impressed with the
caliber of the ones that went through
the final selection process I am
therefore recommending to Council that
Isabelle Edgar Brianna on be appointed
head of food service designate from 1st
of November 2018 and head of paid
service from the first of January 2019
so you have everybody have any questions
for the leader in which case can I have
a proposal in a seconder for that motion
please cancel bunker counselor carriage
seconding it all those in favor anyone
against any abstentions thank you that's
carried we now move on to the slightly
ratio one which is the constitutional
update I call on the leader of the
council to preserve this report on 16th
of May I presented for your information
a document called the leader statement
the one that gives details of all
executive delegations that document is
actually in the agenda papers today it's
attached at the back of the minutes for
the AGM pages 37 to 48 that document was
a work in progress as they've been as
there had been very little time to put
it together following the change in
leadership since then I have reshaped
the document the aim being to remove the
delegations to off
hisses from the statement and place them
all in another part of the Constitution
the scheme of delegations to officers
which is their natural home what's left
in my leader statement is shown at
appendix warm to the report pages 59 to
69 although that's not referenced in the
report aside from the fact that the
office of delegations have been removed
we'll also see a number of other changes
which will be marked for ease of
reference the leader statement is
presented purely for information at the
same time powers delegated to officers
in other parts of the Constitution have
also been brought together in the
offices scheme of delegation mainly
taken from the financial procedure rules
the contents of the report is entirely
devoted to these other parts of the
Constitution which appears at appendix
two pages 72 136 all the proposed
changes are marked say for some changes
in licensing delegations on pages 83 to
84 numbers 19 20 21 the main change has
been to extend office of powers for taxi
licensing where there are where there is
an immediate risk to public safety the
planning delegations page 87 delegation
19 is worth a special mention the
distinction between major and minor
applications is removed and the test as
to who determines a planning application
largely depends on whether or not the
Parish Council or the ward member
objects although we still retain the
provision that allows officers to refer
an application to committee where the
application generates significant public
interest or quotes or in any other
respects merits consideration by the
committee moving to the recommendations
there is a slight amendment of the
wording in that reference to the
appendix should instead read appendix
two finally for clarity the purpose of
the second recommendation is to ensure
that the whole Constitution including
the proposed
changes in appendix 2 are endorsed in
this where the council mitigates the
risk of any future legal challenges I
move the recommendations as amended
councillor Mort Thank You chairman
chairman I've had a number of meetings
and conversations with mr. Grafton over
these proposals and on the vast majority
of points are I have no concerns however
I did have concerns about allowing all
planning decisions to be delegated to
officers unless the decision is taken to
do otherwise by a board member or
committee chairman or parish council or
as we've had explained now in chairman
Jamie's theory this could mean that an
application for a thousand houses 2,000
houses could go through on delegated
powers I would urge chairman that this
power be used very carefully if we are
to maintain public confidence that the
public will not understand if knowledge
applications go through without being
seen by a planning committee thank you
about the leader to respond to her Thank
You chair
I think councillor moss in all honesty
if one has an application of that size I
would anticipate it will generate
significant public interest that should
allow it to go to committee and if in
any other respects it merits
consideration by committee it will go to
committee frankly I can't say that
anything that is likely to cause
problems of a public interest nature or
a public backlash would not go to
committee that is not the point of these
changes I can't sleep ensign did you
retire to comment that
Goethe to officers certainly not under
my watch or anybody else I could imagine
it sitting as the the cabinet member for
Earth for planning and none of us are
about trying to make decisions and take
them away from public overview and
scrutiny so absolutely give you that
assurance counsel courage thank you very
much just on page 87 1941 the change
about if parish counselors or district
councillors don't turn up to a planning
meeting the decision can be delegated to
officers this is I think new and I think
it merits this information being
circulated as a as a note on its own to
both our members and parish councilors
any other members wish to say any make
any comments please bark at the castle
Baca had your hand up thank you in which
case I propose that we move to the
recommendations
we need to propose around a seconder for
these what I'm can we can we take these
recommendations together Yeah right
please can I have a proposal then for
this thank you I'm cancer brain second
right we've proposed and seconded all
those in favor all those against any
abstentions right that's carried then
thank you if we can therefore move on to
0.9 GDP our otherwise general data
protection regulations I've a councillor
waters governance and democracy
portfolio holder uses item thank you
chairman as members may be aware the
general data protection regulations came
into force on the 25th of May 2018 these
regulations require the council to have
a certain data protection policies in
place and to ensure that technical and
organizational measures are in place to
ensure data protection compliance the
policies cover data protection policy
retention and destruction policy and the
ICT code of practice the positive papers
have emerged over some months following
work by the management team ICT the data
protection officer and the legal team
with special thanks to Matt Collins who
sat at the back of the room with his
expertise from a legal point of view on
the 4th of June 2018 tablet were asked
to approve the policy and to recommend
to council that the policy is duly
adopted
therefore through Chairman I ask council
the data protection policy retention and
destruction policy and the ICT Code of
Practice be adopted thank you thank you
so well
any questions for a council thorough
well on this matter
nope right no question at all in which
case can we have a proposer counselor
glitches seconded by Councillor we'll
all those in favor anyone against any
abstentions carried minute fifty a
notice of motion on the corporate
priorities consider recommendations and
cabinets contained in minute fifty and I
believe the council to continue thank
you
consideration was given to the notice of
motion in the names of counselors and
balsam fragile II presented to the
council meeting on 24th of April 2018
the options open the cabinet were
considered the content of the motion at
the meeting without the benefit of a
report from the offices on the
implications to the council of accepting
or rejecting the motion the further
consideration of the motion to work away
at reports from offices to the next
available meeting of cabinets or refer
the motion to the overview and scrutiny
committee for consideration and report
back to the cabinet there was discussion
of cabinet and in the view of the
cabinet considered that there were
adequate measures in place at the moment
to address the compensation issue by the
steering group and their planning
process it was therefore recommended to
counsel that the notice of motion be
rejected for the above reasons right
Thank You leader Calcifer actually I
think you wish to raise yes I just
actually like to say that I think
possibly hs2 is set a benchmark for good
practice in this area in that when
people are going to be heavily impacted
by infrastructure there is a mechanism
for early consultation on compensation
and I think when this planning authority
is asking residents to accept
considerable impact on their lives of
development that
we should have something similar in
place I am very disappointed that this
isn't actually having further serious at
consideration counselor Mort Thank You
chairman members call corporate
priorities the subject arose when the
cabinet decided we've taken too much
council tax off residents and they'd
better spend some money rather quickly
to get the reserves then we also put
some ideas in and these are the ideas
that are being rejected by council today
if this recommendation is followed
through but like council are fragile and
I'd like to pick up on one point in
particular and that is compensation for
residents affected by the southwest
relief road before the main compensation
scheme comes into effect one year after
the road has been opened now it's likely
chairman that between now and then some
residents will have to move according to
the papers before us the council
consider the cabinet considers there are
adequate measures in place at the moment
to address this issue chairman can I
therefore ask if a resident needs to
move next week and is told by an estate
agent or surveyor that the value of
their property is dropped because it's
been blighted by the new road to whom
does that resident apply now for
compensation thank you I lost a leader
to respond on that huh Thank You counsel
as fragile in Morse there have been
discussions going on with Orange County
Council over the compensation issue
those discussions are continuing it is
not an easy or straightforward issue in
part because it counts along the highway
authority although we are the planning
and the sponsor of the world our Karla
Holmes furthermore we don't wish to set
too obvious a precedent which may well
not only impact on this council in the
future but might impact on others all I
can say is that discussions are ongoing
and we are trying to find a solution
Thank You Costa Charles leader thank you
for those comments and I do take them in
good faith but I do urge cabinet and
leader to keep this matter under
constant review this may not be the
mechanism and I am very clear I do feel
in the first instance the obligation for
compensation and to make sure the
terrible blight that this road would
deliver on my residents it is the
responsibility of Karla homes they are
the people who will profit from the
delivery of these homes they other
people have chosen the location of this
road it is not for the taxpayers of this
district to take the financial
obligation of that however the most
important thing from my point of view is
that blight and that compensation is
delivered in the event that this road
does come forward and ultimately if it
comes to the point where this road is
delivered Stratford district taxpayers
are said to be benefitting from it in
the sense that it is claimed to be a
road solution then clearly I would say
that at some point the responsibility
will have to fall on the taxpayer to
compensate those people who will have to
live with that dreadful blight so I
accept at the moment this may not be
this motion may not be the mechanism but
I would like to see further concrete
plans and mechanisms in place to address
this issue thank you they will shortly
be another meeting with Warwickshire
County Council it's not arranged yet but
it will be shortly because we are we
intend to have a common position with
regard to Karla homes on the issue of
compensation
so we are pursuing each on I do
understand the counselor John's concerns
thank you are there any other comments
counselors which to make on this I
haven't spotted any in which case the
recommendations on page one for T and
that is recommendation the can't notice
of motion be rejected for the reason set
out in the report do I have a proposal
for that recommendation and a second
thank you
we've got a propose that and a seconder
all those in favor of the motion that is
that the new semester is rejected all
those in favor all those against fall
against any abstentions two abstentions
right moving on then cabinet segment so
I Basin so mission is is canal quarter
regeneration counselor Pemberton
planning of building services portfolio
holder to introduce item thank you
chairman members the canal quarter is a
key plank of our core strategy it also
affords a huge opportunity to regenerate
a part of the town to the benefit of our
residents both in the town and in the
wider district and to help support
economic development in the town and
across the district the master plan
supplementary planning document is a key
piece of information that supports the
delivery of the canal Porter and it has
been the subject of much work and
discussion
between officers the potential promoters
and developers and this of the site and
at the last what we what used to be
called the leaders policy Advisory Group
in in December of last year a
consultation draft for that document was
brought forward that's identified a
little over 30 different responses from
statutory agencies businesses specialist
bodies parish councils and most
importantly people who live in this
district and the time that document then
has been updated there have been some
minor changes the broad thrust of the
document remains unchanged but certainly
some changing emphasis around
particularly infrastructure biodiversity
foot and cycle ways which I'm sure will
be good news for for councillor fragile
II have been incorporated into the
document as well as a mechanism for
monitoring and reviewing the success of
the delivery of the SPD and it also took
the opportunity to take account of the
examination draft of the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood
development plan that document then came
back to cabinet on the 2nd of July and
is now before council for recommendation
that that document be adopted members
this is a robust detailed and I would
say visionary document that provides a
roadmap to give life to our aspirations
as an authority and as a community to
deliver on regeneration of the canal
Quarter and specifically I'd like to
thank John Kerr furred and all of his
team for the hard and effective work
that they've put in over a number of
months to bring us to this point in
producing the document and members I
would really just draw your attention to
the recommendation that the council
approves the changes identified and
formally adopts the canal Quarter
regeneration zone framework master plan
has as a supplementary planning document
comes from what
Thank You chairman chairman broad be in
support of this two points first of all
we'll have to be for college suggesting
that leads to be conversations between
themselves and the college to see
whether this would be a suitable site
for relocation and redevelopment of the
college it would lend vitality I think
gen to a site that otherwise the second
point I wanted to raise chairman is the
importance of the connectivity between
this site and the center of town and
that depends upon the Gateway project
chairman you will recall that in
December 2014 this council gave a
10-year option over the Windsor Street
car park nothing is happening chairman
but the connectivity is vital can I ask
Germany when are we going to see some
action from this council on the Gateway
project well you go come come this we
were just trying to get our ducks in a
row
I mean I think I mean the point is well
made about ensuring that you know we get
the very best out of the canal quarter
Anders and I think you know we are in a
position where we're open to we haven't
you know there's been no locking down
that parcel of land will be the foot for
that particular organization or whatever
so I think yeah we can take them about
in terms of the connectivity bit yeah
the whole thing is predicated on
ensuring there is great connectivity
between the canal quarter so I think
we're on the same page as far as that is
concerned I think I'm going to defer
particularly on the basis I've been on
holiday for a couple of weeks around any
particular further update around the
Gateway so if I may defer to the leader
for that thank you
Thank You chair
I can honestly say that there is most
definitely something happening on the
gateway we've had an awful lot of
discussions both internally and with the
owner of the site at the moment there is
nothing to announce
well that really does not mean there is
nothing happening an awful lot has been
happening and there have been an awful
lot of discussions going on it would not
be appropriate I think to go any further
at this stage very much I'm very pleased
that cancer Pemberton actually looked me
when he mentioned cycling the issue
about cycling when snow comes back to
connectivity because so often cycling is
facilitated within a development but
when people actually want to cycle or
scooter to school or to work those
connections become very much more
difficult and really much more difficult
to afford because of the way in which
finances are arranged and I'll actually
really really ask that when this comes
forward real hard effort is put into
making those connections actually work
in safe places for people of all ages to
be able to get onto their bicycles just
as a side actually looking at the
Gateway when that hopefully something's
going to happen I have so many residents
saying to me that they will not use the
car park because of its state of it's
appalling state it's dangerous it's a
frightening place to be particularly at
dusk and night and I'd really really
really push for something to happen
there if the development is going to
take a considerable time that should
really be upgraded or made safe for
people to use
Thank You councillor get as' yes thank
you a chairman I guess you know whatever
I hear about gateways and entrances to
Stratford as I come down the road from
Ulster I'm always rather reminded about
the cattle market site which in my view
is an unfortunate end
main entrance to stratford-upon-avon
stratford-on-avon
I guess I'd hoped that we could have
reassurances that in due course they can
now port in the new gateway won't end up
looking over similar nature thank you
Thank You councillor to give you some
assurance I have no idea how to make
this work all the time I was in a
meeting with the promoter and developer
of the canal quarter and as is their
want sometimes with developers they'd
like to tell you how things are going to
be and how wonderful it's going to be
and I used the phrase exemplar and that
is a word I keep throwing back at them
they have committed to providing a site
which is an exemplar I will hold them to
that and this Authority will hold them
to that this will be a good high-quality
site and regeneration project they have
set the bar high and we will ensure that
they get over that bar lead up Thank You
chair I would just like to reassure
councillor ghitis that as far as
Stratford gateway goes we would really
like to see a very high quality
development there it is a very key site
on the entrance to Stratford and it is
vitally important so it is in our
interests to do everything we can to
ensure that that development when it
comes forward is exceedingly high
quality so jahres I would like to thank
officers and councillors for their hard
work in relation to this because it is a
good example of something being able to
be brought forward but enjoy community
support and people feel confident that
it will bring benefits I have to say
without sounding like a broken record
one ought to take this opportunity to
compare this with what the feeling is
around the long master and development
in a southwest relief Road what we
appear to be at being asked to accept
there is a compromise not something
people can enjoy can sell
to our community something we're being
asked to to accept with a great heavy
heart and I think it is an opportunity
to compare those two things so I'm very
happy to support this and I would urge
Council to think about that when they
are developing the future proposals in
relation to other development I'm just
gonna make one comment on myself
councillor mills and I attended the
really training session on urban design
an outing to Northampton where a local
authority owned sites very very
significant a site had been developed in
a number of different styles some which
have say cancer mills I never found
uncomfortable to the eye but it did
demonstrate where if you really work
hard you can get some very imaginative
outcomes with you like them or not
cancer mills and I have recommended to
officers that's in fact that should be
put forward as a training opportunity
for members a significant number
photographs were taken to demonstrate
what can be achieved if you if you look
more to blue sky and think how can we
achieve something really good here
anyway on that basis we should now move
to the recommendation which you set out
on page 143 I need a proposal for that
thank you comes to courage leader
council cargle all those all those in
favor of the recommendation any ones
against recommendation no abstentions
and the abstentions right in which case
the motion is carried
so we move on now to standards committee
and I call on Chancellor Harris and
chair of the committee to introduce item
12
Thank You chair the audience Standards
Committee met on the 25th of June and
we're looking at the community
governance review for gayden and like
Horne Heath we were presented a report
requesting consideration given to stage
one in the community governance review
to change the parish boundaries it
involves four of the local villages
parish areas the different options are
being listed it's for the council to
either accept it goes ahead recommend
reject or request more information and
have put the minute forward one to one
regarding review and the recommendations
to Council for the community governance
review and that our report be made
counts on the 17th of December 2018 with
the final recommendations Thank You
councillor Harris
anybody have any comments questions on
this item in which case I think we'll
move straight to the recommendation and
I would be grateful if with you take
both recommendations together well we
agreed on that thank you
in which case please can I have a pose
up for the recommend recommendations
councillor Harris kind of second
counselor we'll all those in favor the
recommendation any against this
recommendation any abstentions thank you
the recommendation is Carol both
recommendations carried we therefore
move on to 13 committee reports these
are for information only counselor
Harris I'd like you to come back on
order to withstand the standards
committee please Thank You chair yes I
commend this report to the council for
consideration thank you thank you we now
move on to counsel Jefferson and plums
and plants times and pointless committee
thank you chair
I'd like to introduce the committee
reports for employment and appointments
committees 16th of May 15th and 20th of
June 2018 thank you because Jefferson
council Barca every scrutiny committee
Thank You mr. chairman can I commend to
you the report of Oviatt scrutiny
committee of the 4th and the 18th April
the 16th of May the 6th June 2018 which
are available on the website Thank You
councillor Barker council ghitis is vice
chairman of regulatory committee the IES
chairman I'd like to present the reports
or the regulatory committee dated the
16th of May thank you and finally Thank
You councillor get esc' finally accounts
of Jefferson reduct report on cabinet
please Thank You chair I'd like to
present the reports of cabinet on the
23rd of April 4th of June and 3rd of
July 2018 thank you
Casa Jefferson we now move on to
questions now we received 10 questions
from members I would go through them in
chronological order councillor Bromwich
do you have you had a written response
to have a supplementary response right
right
leader thank you first of all for
replying to this however bit confused
because I was asking about the future
and this refers mainly to the past on
that while Sir was historic stuff going
on in South and 10 years ago it's now
2018 in 2010 it was not known that we're
going to have 500 extra houses sou 3
this has a significant impact
we will also promised the steering group
from your predecessor which hasn't
happened on that part there so Lido I
want to point you again that I do you
think it would be wise to honor that
commitment for the steering group to
make sure that we have a third increase
in the size of Southam
and for quite a few the surrounding
villages that we can get the correct
infrastructure to stop these towns sell
them and its surrounding villages
becoming dorm towns I think in the
interest of engaging with the public in
the various areas I think it's important
that we go down this route and try and
get things right from the start
Thank You council obliged I believe I'm
correct in saying that South Salem town
council has set up an infrastructure
task group and there are representatives
from our policy team along with
Warwickshire County Council colleagues
on it and I think that should actually
be able to do some work that the helpers
know exactly what's needed also in terms
of salvan we are of course rolling out
CCTV and rural broadband which should
have a positive impact on sale them you
mentioned in your original question
about the Grange I can confirm that we
are actually looking at that now when
the paper should come to cabinet in the
near future as a rummage your second
question you had a written response from
councilor brain do you have a
supplementary one on that thank you
in which case we move on to councillor
Moore's got some Walsh you had about the
compulsory purchase order on airfield
and I'm told in the response to the
question the issue in relation to the
valuation of a site is a key issue and
further clarification is being obtained
from the council's legal advisors
chairman it is indeed a key issue could
I ask the leader whether he stands by
the statement in the minutes of the 12th
of December 2016 cabinet meeting when we
were told after a CP o has been
confirmed
at this stage it would be too late for
the council to withdraw from the CPO
process northern chairman at that stage
is after that stage of land tribunal has
the value at the site if they value the
site at housing value we could be
talking 100 million pounds plus
so trimming how will the council pay for
that leader would you like to respond on
that thank you I would just say that at
the moment we are taking legal on advice
on exactly what the position is at the
minute I am NOT certain that what was
said to come in it on that date was
actually correct
okay it becomes more real case if we
move on councillor Rolf written response
good thank you very much back to council
Morse
do you have a chairman this is about
clawback agreements and I'm glad to see
there in principle this council is in
support of them but one of the
objections given is that on a previous
occasion it was very difficult to obtain
the from the developer information
because there's no sanction that could
be imposed once the development was
completed no Chairman that's not an
argument against clawback or introducing
it now that's an argument about the
drafting of a section 106 agreement
would the leader not agree
councillor Pemberton sorry not agree
that with the correct wording of the
section 106 and with a sanction
introduced into that it would be
entirely practical to introduce clawback
agreements now Thank You councillor more
so as you can see just just for
everybody's clarity we are in favor of
using clawback as a mechanism as and
when we can do and as and when it's
appropriate it unfortunately we sort of
we're not entirely unfettered in how we
we do this in terms of of how how we can
we can put clawback together and the
point being that yes we just we do you
know if
we should not be in a position where any
agreement this Authority has fetters our
discretion and I don't think that was
actually the case it was actually more
this is actually more about actually
getting to the nub of the information I
think we we are trying to push back as
much as we can and just an olive would
just give assurance to castle the moss
and all other members a number of you
will have heard me say in the past
it ain't difficult to make money
building houses in this district so I
for one I'm not particularly impressed
by our arguments that says it's really
difficult for us so you can rest assured
that whenever there is an opportunity to
hold the I think just very quickly just
yeah I think we are on the same page as
far as this is concerned it is a balance
and I think what factors into that is
what's happening with the impact of
online commerce that's and how that
impacts on our town centers market
centers village centers so it's a
balance it's one and it's going to be a
fast-moving piece this because the world
is changing very very quickly we just
want to get the best outcome so I think
you know it is one just to keep them for
us to keep under review
question 7 counselor frankly
put it on my reading of the s106
agreement is that it is exclusive and
defined rather than inclusive as it says
here and that's the point I'm trying to
make is that there are employments such
as care workers and key workers at that
level which are not included in the
creaky worker description now when that
comes to people performing those very
very important jobs in our community
looking at finding accommodation in this
key worker block it's very difficult I
remember when it came through the
planning process it was asked what the
affordable housing would be on this site
and we were told that wasn't necessary
because these units were going to be
very small and because they were so
small they would be affordable for the
key workers that I'm talking about that
was actually stated as I remember so
when we're looking at one bed at seven
fifty and two beds at eight ninety five
that actually takes it out of that key
worker sort of range really and my point
was if key workers of the care worker
sort of ability are included in that
list then it becomes more possible for
them to make negotiations to work in
such a splendid blockers for us for them
houses its no criticism of fordham house
itself it's a criticism of how we
actually make some of those places
affordable to local key workers of the
care workers sort of range of employment
people in sort of retail and other key
working jobs in the town now Thank You
councillor fragile e Fordham House has
worked and he's achieving what it's set
out to achieve I think the point that
you're making is that if there are any
further lessons to be learnt about how
we make provision for key workers more
available and if we can be more
sophisticated about that as we move
forward that we should take those
opportunities I don't think anybody in
this room could argue with that we've
managed to achieve
development here that that helps key
workers and I think that officers in in
the policy team and off will take on
board your comments and so that for the
next development that looks at this type
of key worker accommodation we ensure
that you know it can be as broad as as
possible at the same time as meeting all
the tests that we need to meet to ensure
that you know various section 106
agreements do stand up to scrutiny thank
you I think we're back to accounts the
right did you have a supplementary have
can I make sure you speak into the
microphone kind of right it was plunging
the wrong direction last time and
switched on it is now I've read the the
literature JMC have put out 400 all and
sundry to read but I'll be concerned
about this whole issue of public
consultation I mean really one press
release on the 22nd of June doesn't
strike me as being very affable for
wanting to really gathering the views he
certainly wasn't in the read each papers
I'm assuming it must have been in the
Stratford papers but it certainly wasn't
with us and the other thing that weighs
heavily on me is how the information is
put together to identify very local
needs I think that's important because
if you look at the two towns Biddeford
uneven for instance has a much younger
population than Studley we're all old
ears instantly and our needs are very
different and how they're getting to
so my question is will there be some
really close looking of what their
information reveals or will it be just
generic figures that says we'll have a
million pound piece of equipment there
and everybody in that area can do to it
we know they can't have that sort of a
quick you know whatever the word is in
each area but there are community issues
that should be really identified and I
would anticipate whoever on this for us
representing us would actually ensure
that the information is very localized
and not generic Thank You counsel Justin
I just like to comment on that
particular point and just to say that
I'm kind of carries as well we're on
that and we both agree with you it's
it's it's not it's not really formed yet
in fact the last meeting was a bit of a
chaotic meeting I couldn't even attended
and others didn't as well one of the
questions that was raised the very very
first meeting was granularity of the
data how are we going to find it I could
also say that the particularly you're
talking about is one of the largest
geographical areas over JLA in the
county and I raised the exact same point
so saying well how can you actually have
the same detail of data at this what at
the bottom end as you can at the top end
and there was no real answer to that
however what they did say there were two
streams of gathering data that we're
going to be brought together at some
point in the future right I can only say
that we're on the case I'm going to keep
an eye on this one because I think we
are exactly on the same page on this
particular point and that's the other
thing I thought it was a completely
unrealistic timetable from day one and
that was something they also said so it
may have to be extended I hope so
because if we handle the data then it's
a worthless exercise
[Music]
the question that I was bringing to you
about talking to the public and the bond
press release that I never saw but I
said Thank You counsel they'd counsel
right I think they've had your
opportunity
I think councillor Jefferson was gonna
make a comment as well thank you I think
just build on what councilor Carville
said I attended the first meeting of
this Jasna it was very obvious at that
meeting that there was perhaps little
understanding amongst the officers of
the size of the geographical area
covered
there was also perhaps their lack of
understanding about how different the
communities were this is at the end of
the day a Warwickshire County Council
initiative all I can say is we will push
very hard for them to do a good job for
the residents of our district and that
may well be quite difficult because one
of the things Warwickshire County
Council made very clear at that first
meeting was the limited resources
they've actually got now there does come
a point when you say well okay if you
only do something once over likely what
may the benefits be and there is no
doubt for an area of our size as a as a
district where there are five five ijs
and their areas within it these areas
are going to be big and cover a
multitude of very different communities
and it is something we will as a
district have to keep a very close eye
on thank you comes from Jefferson
councillor frankly
question number nine you've had a
written response very happy well content
except I would like to know what time
scale is on bringing forward any sort of
organization to hear the views in terms
of timescales I don't know and in terms
of what Bridget actually means I don't
know so I think that there are some
interesting imponderables in this but it
certainly is going to be a key issue as
things become clearer certainly there's
no problem at all working with the LGA
and they'll take it up with them to see
what help they can provide may I just
ask that you keep me informed of the
progress of your deliberations indeed
thank you Kosar Rolf
in which case there are no more councils
I move on to the questions for the
leader I now invite questions from I
think it comes to Rolf just because of
foot checks sorry
rule number two girls who roll Thank You
chair at the last council meeting
when council estate was leader he wasn't
present and there was no time for
questions to the leader we were asked to
email the leader with our questions
I didn't mail the leader with my
question but because the leader at the
time was and well I never received a
response so I'm going to talk to Council
Jefferson about plastic cups and stores
and I think we should lead by example
with the council and I think we should
get rid of our coffee machines and I
think we should get rid of our plastic
cups now plastic stirrers and I think we
should introduce our of councillors we
should bring in our own cup we should
bring our own spoons and I'm even going
to offer on a temporary basis of
collecting money from every counselor
and buying the coffee tea and sugar as
long as we can use the kitchen next to
the members room so I'd like that to be
put forward thank you and it was put
forward months ago to the then leader
Jefferson Council organ could respond on
my behalf
thank you yes replacement coffee
machines are currently being looked at
and looked at with a view to reducing
and getting rid of the plastics etc etc
and also being more user friendly
just doing your school Facebook machines
can we not just use the kitchen next
door and we make our own coffee and tea
I'm sure the point is well made and
everybody understands in the current
climate Council golf next rows can
support check questions the first one is
a clean air campaign as a calling on the
government to ban parents driving their
children to the school gates in an
attempt to cut down on toxic there was a
pollution environmental groups and
medics warned that pollution from the
school run is having a serious impact on
young people's health
this issue is a serious concern to the
health of children and Stratford
district colleges schools and nurseries
and action must be taken by staff a
district council to pressure
Warwickshire County Council to find ways
to encourage more children to walk to
school or cycle already some local
authorities take an action on this issue
and they're looking at best practice
from other councils can the leaders show
me that this concern is brought up with
the County Council to find ways to keep
our children safe from the dangerous
toxic chemicals that are created
everyday outside the school gates and
the second question is so that was
highlighted last night actually from
some residents concerns in Stratford
regarding antisocial behavior large
numbers of car enthusiasts in Stratford
huge amounts of noise and a large amount
of people that have been complaining
about it
it seems to there that nothing is being
done and will the leader give me an
assurance that be calling on the police
to take more action Thank You councillor
Jefferson we don't respond to both
questions
Thank You chair if I may pick up the
second question first counselor phytic
we are well aware of the antisocial
behavior in car parks we've been aware
of it for some time
we have been requesting that the police
do something we are now cranking up the
pressure on them to actually do
something because it is now across at
least two car parks and it needs dealing
with and all I can say is I less than
happy with the way the police have
responded to the very legitimate
concerns of residents on this issue
turning to the first question in terms
of encouraging children to walk or cycle
to school this is certainly something we
will take up with the County Council
thank you are there any other questions
I can saban sorry I did notice you
apologize
well thank you I was going to ask a
question in the respective at your first
cabinet meeting mr. leader we had a
report from the Garden City in the
respect of the rail link which was
obviously too expensive
number one was accepted and we agreed
with us
number two was put forward as a road and
rail link should be looked at the study
for the whole area which is six the
right thousand houses I wondered if
there was any update thank you
Thank You counselor Barnes there is a
piece of work going on at the moment
we're not ready to report back on it yet
counselor fradulent just an update to
counsel for tick actually um as County
counselor I'm on the cycle task and
finish group and safer routes to school
so I'm very gladly updating where we are
in that respect at the moment well any
further questions comes from furniture
because you need your microphone right
any castle bromwich yeah this question
Simo sort of lines to my written
question
last year met with the portfolio hold on
myself and councillor Crump I have a
very nice drink we must say on a nice
night
and we wrote down a wish list as part of
the sou 3 development what's happened to
that wish list and is anything can ever
be taken from it and actually
implemented within Southam almost a
Bromwich have no idea I will find out
and get back to you
did somebody else have a question
right there are no more questions for
the leader we'll move on to point 16
motions and notice I call on councillors
fragile II and roll from frozen second
your motion as set out on the agenda and
I second it thank you
okay so
in accordance with the council procedure
rules the Chairman's report that the
motion once proposed and seconded would
refer the cabinet for consideration and
report with that debate that takes on
point 17 I've not been informed of any
items of urgent business and therefore
and the absence of anything further on
the agenda I now declare the meeting
closed
you've got the loudest